ti piace
[Musica]
verrà dimenticato che le cuffie c'hanno
cavo e tutti sti cazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj la
gestione e un nuovo fantastico
incredibile e meraviglioso epico unlock
prima di cominciare come al solito di
ripartire con la fama della settimana
che questa settimana è stata vinta da di
morta scimmia che non mi ricorda questa
ragazza che ha fatto un disegno figo
perché mi dimentico le ragazze perché
quando mi disegnate non mi disegnate
anche con l'alzheimer perché all
alzheimer quindi dovete mettercelo
comunque sei ragazzi passando alle news
c'è un po poco profondi di robe da dire
perché fatto che sono andato a monza ho
incontrato vale sono più alto di vale
solo che io dica pezzo mi sono
emozionato pochissime volte in tutta la
mia vita
nell'incontrare una persona questa è
stata una di quelle volte wow è stato
bello che non è anche la patente però il
solo fatto di avere la foto con
valentino questo conferisce patente
quindi adesso posso andare in giro con
la macchina e mi fermano faccio vedere
la foto è la polizia molta ma siccome mi
va di fare le cose al contrario oggi
facciamo prima fa vi risponde poi tutto
il resto troppe se gara allora ragazzi
la prima domanda di oggi che non è una
domanda ma è una poesia che mi ha
dedicato una ragazza in sti giorni che
mi hanno eletto rete stupenda proprio
gli fa capire l'amore che provasse nei
miei confronti ragazzi è stupendo
davvero io la leggerò davanti a voi
perché mi è bellissimo
lorenzo e delle gambe stupende
ma io parlo di quella in mezzo si
intende oggi oggi ieri era ieri io con
te lo farei ascoltami gara se vuoi
provare a esprimere le tue emozioni che
queste ti arrivano da dentro c'è si
sente proprio che arrivano non è finita
forse non sai che nella mia vita non
sono mai stata così per partita madonna
ave sono io che ti faccio scattare il
fuoco dentro con amore la tua futura
moglie a cui file che vuol dire ai
ragazzi veramente io della poesia
non ho mai capito un cazzo nel senso che
io ho provato sempre a dedicare poesie
romantiche alle ragazze ma da adesso in
avanti il tuo sorriso è il più bello
della piazza
e pensare che ancora non hai visto la
mia mazza pieno di [ __ ] posso già
adocchiarlo all'orizzonte sarà formicola
anche la gamba ogni tanto quando la
poggia male chissà quante volte parlan
detto cosa del genere tanto sono
simpatiche risponde domanda seria o
quando non avevi tanti iscritti tipo
cento per la qualità e o il genere di
video sei mai stato preso in giro a
scuola
hai mai sofferto di bullismo aqsa bella
domanda
quando avevo avevamo il canale vecchio
del gaming che eravamo io i miei due
amici vedete ogni tanto nelle mie foto
ultimamente ha in realtà presi in giro
non venivamo presi in giro però io mi
ricordo vista pronto queer e abbiamo
fatto il mio compagno di classe dove
c'era la mia faccia il tsg sarebbe
acronimo di lesce ritieni sono del tsg e
poi c'è la mutanda bagnata che sarah
aveva fatto al mio compagno per
prenderci per il culo per prendere per
il culo anche me l'avrebbe mai detto che
adesso è proprio così specialmente
quando ballo bullismo no io sono sempre
stato quello un po amico di tutti però
una volta una provata una persona una
persona ragazzino
la mia età aveva provato a rovigo eta
attaccarmi perché siccome io sono molto
magro un po come quando si prende in
giro ragazzi cicciottello continuava a
dire assai magro magro poi ha capito che
effettivamente prendere una scarpata in
bocca faceva male anche se ero magro
però no non è istigazione adesso io
invece ricevuto un sacco di messaggi da
parte vostra e molte volte mi capita che
alcuni di voi mi scrivono che hanno di
questi problemi non fatevi mai togliere
la felicità da nessuno perché nessuna
persona merita di toglierla nessuna
molti mi scrivono mi rende felice con i
tuoi video tantissime volte mi arrivano
sempre questi messaggi dio solo sa
quanto mi rende orgoglioso sapere che io
in qualche modo riesco a esservi utile a
nessuno nessuno mai deve essere in grado
di togliere la felicità vedete io anche
un sacco di scritti su due milioni e
passa so non so quanto caso siamo ho
anche tanti haters però io degli hate
viene sempre sempre sbattuto il cazzo ma
perché per me non lo sono microbi nel
senso che non mi interessano come
sarebbero stati microbi i bulli perché a
me il parere di una persona che non
conosco
lo scrivo sulla carta igienica e mice
pulisco il culo se qualcuno vi insulta e
non lo conoscete quel qualcuno non vi
conosce quell'insulto non vale un cazzo
ma veramente un cazzo basta argomenti
tristi passiamo a prossimo vice domande
perché non chiede mai un certo numero di
mi piace nei tuoi video ma perché video
te mi piace a noi che servono più di
tanto quasi completamente inutile rega
pollici in su per chi la pensa come me
se arriviamo al meno 80 mila mi piace
giro per casa a nudo con un calzino nel
culo stavo scherzando non arriverà 80
mila mi piace questo video che si
scherza prossima domanda ma visto anche
fare un video in cui canti da come sei
stonato potrei morire guarda fra te e mi
sono attrezzato aspetta un paio di
giorni vincenzo ma notifiche ma è lo
spazio in casa con tutta la roba che ti
mandiamo questo te ne fai della roba
vecchia fa che il signore la roba tengo
tutta questi erano della settimana
scorsa del blog scorso ma la butto io se
si arrivò al limite che non ci sta più
un cazzo cambio casa però come ho fatto
infatti questa casa nuova la cambierò
quando non avrò più spazio ai ragazzi è
conclusa col fare risponde è stato l'ho
voluto fare un po prima perché oggi mi
girava così anche perché alle volte di
news non è che io ne abbia così tante da
poter fare chissà cosa
a posto al massimo dirvi che mi si è
bruciata la cucina mentre tentavo di
fare il tè e mi sono bruciato anche il
dito è vero stavo facendo il tè come ho
alzato il pentolino dell'acqua perché
stava facendo te mi si è rovesciata
l'acqua sul vito infatti qua c'è la
bruciatura ho dovuto appoggiare subito
il lapentti pentolino e sono andato a
sciacquarmi il dito il pentolino rovente
l'ho lasciato quando sono tornato dal
sesso perché mi sono fidato dito nel
cesso ho guardato sotto il pentolino e
ho trovato questo è una chiazza di
bruciatura perché si è bruciato la
cucina e stavo solo facendo un tempo i
ragazzi di trasportare e cucina a
[ __ ] il vero che mia madre non sa di
questa cosa quindi si incazzerebbe
altamente a saperlo spero che mia madre
non guardo i miei blog passando invece
alla news
quella vera a parte gli scherzi domenica
6 dicembre al web land farò un fa vi
risponde tipo quello di prima in live
cioè nel senso
sul palco ci sarà veramente figlio ma
detto questo ragazzi passiamo allo
scarto dei bachi fiera che a soli
abbiamo altri tre pacchi belli a datati
di anni solo prevedere se mi avete
regalato altre uova di pasqua visto che
siamo in periodo oro giallo promette
sempre bene che fa pan dan con la mia
maglietta spero che ti piacciono fatto
interamente con le mie mani anche se un
po brutto per farvi j
anche mia mamma mi ha fatto con le sue
mani e sono brutto quindi ti capisco ma
dovrebbe essere sembrate sentito è un
cappello è staccato il cappello di una
tua felpa per fare un cappello per me
grazie e dopodichè mi ha inviato una
catena che queste sono delle manette
credo che sia sadomaso sadomaso con
questo cappello perché questo cappello
così come le poesie a rapano degli
occhiali cos'è john lennon di altri
tempi ragazza assieme al prossimo
sentiti ragazzi il rumore che fa sto
pacco se lo giro il cazzo c'è un
transformer la cosa più importante le
bacchette per mangiare giapponese sono
giappone ed io mangio limite tre volte a
settimana susciti in teoria su anche
prendere mia nonna
stavo scherzando e molti nuova rom per
importanza il pacco marrone
mio dio perché la faccia di chi devo
attaccare qua sopra
per concludere una cosa che contiene dei
dolci tipo befana che anche quella
passata da un po però la riciclo che poi
tanto siamo li vedi ragazzi detto questo
direi che posso concludere con lo scarto
sempre piero ecco infatti adesso dovrò
cambia casa patrono ancora arredato un
cazzo poco la voglia 0 prima di congiure
ragazzi voglio farmi la domanda sul
gameplay che andrò a fare tra poco dove
prova a cantare cose c'è scritto che
devi avere una bella voce io sono a
posto
siccome lo farò una volta perché una
volta mi rovino la vita e basta mi sono
già distrutto la carriera di ballo
almeno quella di canto distruggiamo ce
l'ha come si deve cosa volete che io
canto e ditemi voi e avrete l'orgasmo
musicale che desiderate e dei ragazzi
che con quello che l'episodio spero che
i video vi sia piaciuto e cosa se vi è
piaciuto al momento è un mi piace anche
la pace ma non a rivalta 80.000 like che
sono cazzi anche a progetti facebook con
e video tra tedeschi si anche se avessi
di stranieri ci vediamo al prossimo
video belle ragazze